be proud of what you create I think it's
super important that for entrepreneurs
you make something that you're proud of
I think too many entrepreneurs mail it
in I think too many entrepreneurs put
out something that's just okay that's
just good that's just average and I
think you know this may not be always
something that only 11 entrepreneur can
always do that you're going to be up and
down right you'll have moments where you
want to be proud of everything you
create the other moments where you're
kind of packaging a little bit but today
I want to challenge you to really be
proud of the things that you create the
books that you're riding the social
media content you're creating the
newsletter that you're sending out the
website that you're doing I want you to
look at what your cravings and say I'm
proud of this I want my grandkids to see
this and say here's what grandpa Evan
did that matters to me this is your
legacy and again I think too many
entrepreneurs just mail it in and put
something out that's just okay and so
yeah I put a lot of work into it but
it's just kind of okay stuff instead of
something that's truly great so how this
relates to my book I'm working my book
as the first time doing like a black
version of an update because I've got to
do a lot of work today all right I'm in
my review mode I'm in the final stages
of of creating it and now it's going
through every single page and making
sure that I'm proud of it so this is
this is also message to myself this is a
message to me that I want to be proud of
every single page as in that book right
in them and I don't want to feel like I
you know how to kind of mail the Dane on
that title or that sentence I want it to
be gold and that's what I'm gonna be
doing today as soon as I good enough
this call I'm going to be basically for
the next 12 hours probably reviewing the
book going through every single page to
make sure it's something that I love and
so challenge you guys who did the same
thing look at the work that you're doing
today and create something that you're
proud of that you could hang your hat on
the say I made that even if it doesn't
take off even though it doesn't blow up
you know that you created something
special deep and meaningful hey grandpa
Evan hey Zeno great to have you here on
the blab I'm going to hit a few
questions that came in from the YouTube
channel because
that's what I usually do when I answer
my book stuff so the first one came in
Amanda nilo congrats on finishing the
book must be a huge piece of joy about
the difficult part of the process what
is the best way to secure an agent or
should I go directly to an independent
publisher first off thank you it is a
huge piece of joy it's it's is this week
39 this is serious you know 39 weeks of
working on something it's it's creating
a child here so thank you I appreciate I
appreciate the love and respect their
and transit security agent what I did
was I had a normal agent like a
entertainment agent the person
responsible for booking you into
speaking gigs and negotiating deals for
you and getting brand deals he
introduced me to a literary agent and
the literary agent then goes out and
sells you and to the different
publishers and we ended up having I
forget how many publishers she contacted
but we had five calls back to back to
back on two different days basically
putting the publishers against each
other so I would say it depends on what
your goal is if your goal is you want to
do you want to have a big reaches why I
started to write a book because I wanted
to do things I want the work on projects
had a potential to reach millions of
people and I wasn't interested in doing
some publishing because it's not a money
grab for me it's more about impact and
reach and getting the message out there
and I figured with a well-known
publisher that would be I have a bigger
potential impact and just trying to do
it myself and so the agent helps with
that you could do the same route that I
went in terms of first finding a regular
agent like a business agent and then
going to find a literary agent or just
hop right to the literary agent it
really depends these days on your
audience it was a lot easier for me
because I already have an audience and
they rely a lot on the author to kind of
spread the spread the word get the buzz
going and so if you're a first-time
author and you don't have an audience
it's going to be a lot harder but I
would definitely recommend trying to
work through an agent if you can as
opposed to go into independent
publishers because they set up better
deals for you they know what publishers
are looking for which deals right now
who the right contact is to get in touch
with and you could try to invest all
that time so that you can't learn that
just takes potential years to get into
it and understand
the dynamics and the connections and who
the people are we're really I don't want
to spend the time doing that I want to
spend time writing the book and Mark it
and getting it out there so I would
recommend going agent to help you get
the publisher if the agent will take you
on because you may not be big enough yet
then you can look at doing it yourself
Xena unfortunately got to do this one
thing and eat no worries Ino enjoy your
lunch next Pete for 725 congrats on the
pre edition of the book now the question
I really need help with I've recently
acquired a new job as a YouTube channel
manager for a huge company CEO I'm going
to be taking care of their content and
their channel directly and I feel it's a
great opportunity none like I have had
but it seems like a high enough level
that I need some advice or tips if you
have ever experienced something like
this hope to hear your thoughts thanks
again and congrats Pete awesome thanks
for the question and thanks for the love
and feeling it so I don't know who the
CEO is that you took over from and
you're helping manage your account but I
look at my experience i'm working with
with with sage right and work with
Steven Kelley he's a CEO of sage they
have 15,000 employees a huge business on
the london stock exchange in Europe so I
don't know if your company is bigger
than that or not but that's a sizable
business most content on big companies
YouTube channels suck period and it
doesn't matter how will you optimize the
title and add descriptions and add tags
and create playlists and reach out to
influencers and do all the stuff that
you're supposed to do if the content
sucks it's never going to take off and
this is one of the biggest thing that I
struggle with and fight with with sage
is that the content even right now on
their YouTube channel for the most part
socks is boring and so there's no no no
reason to put in marketing dollars to
promote it because the product is crap
and I look at their competitors one of
their competitors has a popular YouTube
channel popular because they're spending
a hundred thousand dollars plus a month
in YouTube ads to drive people to see
their videos and there's no engagement
and there's no subscribers because their
videos suck too and so you know I don't
want to give you the tactical advice
because in all likelihood it's not going
to do much for you reality what you need
to do is make sure that you're putting
out quality content and often it starts
with the CEO I'm lucky in that I'm
working with sage and Stephen Kelly is a
man on
and is somebody who people want to hear
from and you know needs a little work on
the messaging and the examples but the
dude has fire he has passion he was have
an impact on the world it's not just
about I'm gonna get on and talk about
stage and how great a company this is
right the guy actually cares and so I
would try to tap into someone who
actually cares if it's a CEO most likely
they'll care the most ideally if they
don't care then you're in a big problem
I try to make content with that like
make the company accessible make them
human do a daily vlog with the CEO where
they're you know working out and had a
quick message or they're flying from one
country to another and there at the
airport ins just a quick shout out right
30 seconds the content that I make with
Stephen Kelly right now is the best
content that sage has globally on their
YouTube channels and so they can use
that to write on their channel so I'd be
looking at how can i leverage the
personality of the people involved to
make a personal connection because the
challenge with a lot of big companies is
you don't feel connected to the person
up there you don't feel connected to the
person who who founded this or who the
CEO is and it looks too boring and if if
I have a choice as a consumer to buy
from a company where I have no
connection to them or buy from a company
where I feel the founders story and I
feel the passion that they have I'm
gonna go with the store i'm going to go
with the passion is and so the challenge
for you is to bring that out of the CEO
and put it out there that will probably
my number one tip to help you build that
YouTube channel up King a lot hi Evan
when is your book planned to be released
will it be available in europe thanks
Aaron you inspire me a lot with your
mini pelipper videos I'm very eager and
excited to get a copy of the book I know
this would be the best book I appreciate
that King a lock King a lock cool name
so release date initially it was
supposed to be January as I mentioned it
a couple times in the channel I know a
lot of you guys wrote in to say you
wanted for the holiday season and so
given that feedback to them and we're
trying to make it for december now
instead of january a lot has to happen I
don't know everything that has happen
between now and June December to get the
book out but that's our new timetable to
get it up for you guys will be available
in europe I'm hope
so I don't know again about too much of
the marketing details we did get the
go-ahead to do an audio version of the
book and a deluxe eBook version of the
book and a lot of that again came from
you guys giving feedback and suggestions
and ideas so in terms of languages
they're open to it I need to figure out
kind of where and what languages if it's
just English version in Europe I'm
assuming that that's going to be
released but as I have more details
information i will let you know you know
a hardcore loyal fan gotta make sure
that the book gets in your hand one way
or the other even if i have to buy it
for you and should be the chief it out
that you're cool well thank you guys so
much for watching i'm going to go back
into deep book writing editing reviewing
and creating again make something you're
proud of today do something that you
would be proud to show your mom showing
your kids showing your friends and say I
made this do that today and have a great
day so it is what time is it it's 1030
it's been another crazy day it's been a
what 14 hour day just finished reviewing
the book editing it down I'm so happy
it's so solid it's so awesome just
feeling overwhelming joy right now the
only thing that's left that I have to
write as a conclusion and I have about
5,000 words to be able to do that and so
that shouldn't be a problem i just sent
everything to my editor or my publisher
again to look at and get feedback but
hopefully everything comes back okay
because i would release it as is just so
much so much gold it's so tight i love
it what Nina's blowing me kisses back to
your friend I'm overwhelmed I'm just
overwhelmed with happiness you know
Marion my editor gave me some good
feedback and the 20 people that I gave
it to give me some amazing feedback and
made some changes anyway I'm really
happy and and also super happy with my
supportive wife who's put up with me
recently I haven't spent as much time as
I I'd like to or normally do because
it's been just crazy book writing and
editing mode
and once they get into that mode is kind
of hard to shake me out of it and I just
want to finish it so yeah I will keep
you guys updated thank you for the
continuous love and support I really
feel it I can't believe I have to wait
to like december for it to come out I
want it out now and I'll keep you
updated appreciate it guys I'll see you
soon